hey guys i'm ryan right i'm gerry so
today it's nostalgia for Jay and I we
actually met this man once he spent some
time with us to say like hey how'd you
like my movie and you guys are in the
film too and he's really took an
interest in us Judd Apatow all rights
Judd Apatow habitat doing stand-up which
is interesting because I remember he
said that he started doing Santa didn't
think it was for him then he so he sat
down and started writing the starter
writing and he became a writer and
director now he's doing stand-up I want
to see this thank you very much I know
it's how's that exciting to see me i I'm
not that famous this is my level of him
if I'm walking down the street and
somebody says are you Judd Apatow if I
say no they go all right my kids don't
find me funny which really pisses me off
because that's all I have yeah I think
every kid thinks her dad is goofy even
like Johnny Depp's kid must be like oh
god my dad with those freaking scarves
this isn't a pirate ship its costco dad
I live with a three women three
beautiful women three ages of the same
woman actually and and I'm like the
weird guy in the house you know because
they have so many things in common they
can talk about they talk about their
hair and how to make the curl look right
how to wax your eyebrows and I'm just
like the weird guy just going can you
pop a zit on a testicle
and I'm not kind of like into being like
an ugly guy I'm very Pro ugly so it's
weird living with three beautiful women
you know I'm always like the troll in
the corner yeah I know that you know you
don't know people really like you and
you're attracting people like me from my
personality beauty fades I mean yeah
people always like me all right now my
daughter is 17 years old there's
employees coming around and every time a
boy comes running direction yesterday
Stan just strike suit you know I think
that and then everyone sounds like we're
food was really like a constraint a
weird kid and sometimes I think oh
that's me that's me in high school and
I'll say to my daughter why didn't you
date that kid I didn't she'll go cuz
he's a nerd I'm like you understand it's
gonna show people one day this body's
gonna fill out and continue to fill out
I very proud of the Jews it feels like
we're not getting in that much trouble
these days or in the world we're doing
well we don't mind if you draw us or
draw our God's yeah and we should mind
because any accurate drawing of a Jewish
person is inherently anti-semitic a
perfect drawing of me is like Nazi
propaganda
Cosby is still out on the road is that
weird he's like doing stand-up what do
you think is act as like do you think
he's still talking about it you think
he's like says like you ever been in
trouble with the wife Jim Joe Cosby
impression and get me get into the dog
house with the white here in the dog
house of the life this is something that
you did like the other day and they were
something battery in the paper and I did
what my wife to read the paper so i got
up at five in the morning and I snuck
out to the driveway to get the paper and
I hit the paper and the next day I got
up I hit the paper that the next day I
forgot to get the paper at my wife she
said to me what is this in the paper
about the rape me to the drugging in the
living and I said do you like your life
do you like the house the jet will then
they have a cappuccino and shut the
flowing capital is an interesting
experience I mean it's like you eat you
kind of don't expect like a whole lotta
judd apatow for that but you do expect
to be pleasantly surprised yeah you
expect yeah right we're not like great
stand-up comedians were Savior but we've
no I'm terrible we follow a lot of
comics it's just a little surprised
because it does sound like someone is
currently in stand-up class I'm writing
stand-up routine well no yes this feels
like watching a guy at the comedy club
who's like clearly watched a lot of
standard he's well versed in stand-up
history stuff like that he knows the
structure and just King would get like a
fresh or sort of out there topic enough
to make the punchline work cuz like his
sets are all right it's the punchlines
that deserve yeah I was very very much
like mmm like I've heard people make
that joke before actually well yeah I
mean it's no not stretching yeah he
really was a talent I Cosby impression
and Sears the things like John Abbott
I'll like we know him for you know his
his movies like his you know scripted
stuff and even those have a lot of
improv in them so like you know we know
him from sketch and improv but I feel
like you know just having done a little
comedy it's like those are three very
different mindsets like your brain is
wired one way for standup wired a
different way for improv wired a
different way for sketch I feel like
every comic or comedian has a different
level of each of those three my level is
reactions that's a nice little improv
I guess it's improv is it prosim
probably say it's like my our brains are
soon were asked for improv but you you
can do Stan them I'm not very good at
standing so like Judd Apatow is probably
more wired as a sketch writer and not as
wired as a stand though yeah well judge
you let us down if you're new to the
channel you can subscribe to the real
rejects you can check out reasons to
Jerry on this channel and but honesty
Judd Apatow I love his movies and a
train wreck just got like amazing
reviews I know what we're gonna see it
and I mean there was a really special
memories yeah I wouldn't meet him this
doesn't make me like not respect you
know we still love you man I just maybe
take another stand-up guy yeah i still
love all i still i even i was watching
funny people last week and I still like
that movie even though like no one does
I I like it and we're gonna be going to
VidCon this week so videos are a little
bit delayed and uploads whatever videos
convention work at this convention that
youtube today yoga Toby we're gonna go
down there for you to want to go to the
YouTube conventional w two people now
I'm gonna do you do I said Jeremy Jahns
yaasiin tacular jenna Marbles yet tits
are huge Oh what if we meet her that's
already guys won't be over for me be
like do you know who I am have you not
seen the channel this is how I talk yeah
beauty pie I hear you love reaction
videos when I created spider-man